si bien feuille ciseaux le sar ans
lauréate et y club près de 400 licenciés
avec des athlètes de niveau national et
international
après avoir testé le tennis et le basket
à gloria haguenau magnon a découvert
l'athlétisme
ici elle avait 11 ans allez rapide
rapide rapide rapide précis rapides
précis rapides précis attiré par le
spiegel a très vite été repéré pour ses
qualités aux lancers atteinte d'une
légère déficience mentale
elle s'est épanouie par le sport plus
ouverte plus autonome
elle s'est métamorphosée au contact de
ses partenaires et de son entraîneur l'a
son handicap qui la gêne un petit peu au
quotidien surtout dans les cours aussi
mais par contre sur le sur l'athlétisme
ça se voit pas quand elle est sur le
stade quand je lui demande d'effectuer
quelque chose va son corps n'a même
comprendre plus vite que certaines
personnes que j'ai dans le groupe donc
ça c'est une grosse qualité
l'apprentissage technique
je garde du retard ici et je pars médias
que derrière ça puisse enchaîner
à 22 ans elle vient de décrocher sa
sélection pour les jeux paralympiques de
tokyo au lancer de poids avec sa
technique bien particulière
gloria elle lance en rotation donc il ya
deux techniques sur la translation glide
leur tâche se nomme égard elle tourne
donc l'idée c'est de donner beaucoup de
vitesse au poids voilà et sans s'arrêter
donc il ya beaucoup beaucoup de travail
d'équilibré un pivot au départ et
ensuite essayer d'aller passer très
large pied droit à donner de la vitesse
au poids actuellement en bac pro métiers
de la mode de gloria disposent d'un
emploi du temps aménagé pour ses études
elle a trouvé son équilibre dans la
pratique de faim sport en fête le lancer
ses sources de libération pour moi ça me
permet de me vider de devoir de vider de
tout là de toute la journée et du coup
voilà c'est quelque chose qui me détend
quand je rentre chez moi après je suis
bien je me posais six séances par
semaine pour la championne record perso
13 mètres 22 elle espère atteindre les
14 d'ici l'été un podium sur les jeux
paralympiques épreuve mythique
pourquoi par contre c'est pas tout le
monde qui qui peut faire les jeux donc
pour moi c'est une grande chance une
grande opportunité pour moi de me
montrer qui je suis en route vers tokyo
avec le soutien de tous les supporters
allez gloria le slack est là
on est bien